in the multi viral
as they define his music he tried it
I will not be able to define spinning
everything for me has so many aspects
street 13 what
what is better to feel it as an energy
that is there and that is 13th street
I would say that you represent a
Latin resistance at a certain point
How do you respond to that which is
how they represent a fight that's how
a double-edged knife because that is
all those titles that put us where
we represent a fight and all that we
it turns out we sometimes
counterproductive
this
there are people who misunderstand they believe that
we grab that baton and we want
we feel that we are the
revolutionaries that we want to represent
to everyone and that is not true and I
I prefer to simplify the basics we do
honest music we document a moment
a time by means of music and
when they ask us for help we are there to
help
Well here we are in the USA and the
people from a recital here in san
francisco are screaming boricua
Mexican people are very energized
very energized worth for their countries by
Latin America I do not know I think they fill a
empty there yes I do not know if it's politics or something
more I think it's all I hope you're
The entire proposal is composed of
in many issues it's not just the political
not only the social brings love too
dance is educated occur I have no more
trivial
and then I go
that's just what life is about with a
moment in the life of any being
human that the moment of love the
moment of dancing political moments there
moments to help in moments of
discomfort the moment of being happy and
that is what we propose that
must understand people about puerto rico
and its relationship with the us a new
puerto rico in a colony of states
united of a small amount wants
be independent independence not
it means that you hate the us or what
you are going to make enemy now of it not
can be friends the other way around that they can
negotiate you can open to negotiate with
different countries
you do not have to be asking for permission
to a country to do anything not
you have to go to war for wars
that are not yours
you have a president by whom you vote
we do not vote for obama but let's go
our president is like half
unfair is super old-fashioned what
what is happening put up
after the time I do not know about the
colonizers that we are still a
colony is like having slaves still
although there are slaves I think that still
there are slaves
this here the many emigrants who
they work for nothing
but then like having slaves with him
whip the same in a colony of these
heights is ridiculous
do not come to me
conversation